meet the prabha the most important thing
is to understand what the elements are
viable story idea and to
make coming up with one your main
priority and take the time and get the
feedback necessary on your just ideas
before you launch into six months or a
year or even several years writing and
rewriting a script because you can write
and rewrite a script endless times but
to make it somewhat better but if it's
based on an idea that really was always
gonna have a tough time moving forward
no matter how you execute it a manager
an agent would call that somewhat wasted
time
any story you can talk about epic poem
you can talk about a myth you can talk
about a fairy tale or children's book
they're all built on character desire
and conflict every story that I can
think of almost without exception if
it's a narrative story that I was a
beginning middle and end it's going to
about it be about a character who
desperately wants something and
something stands in their way it has to
have a hook that gets people instantly
involved in the story and and that is a
huge part of the story itself and it's
it's got to have a very strong character
in the story that you care about and
other than that it has to have twists
and turns that lead to a surprise ending
and like if I had to just say three
things I guess that's what I would say
the three things are every every story
needs that because a story about nothing
it's not gonna hold anyone's interest
and and sometimes writers when they
begin their careers think that they just
if they just write they can write about
anything but the truth is they need to
write from their heart about things that
matter to everyone and if they do that
you can hardly go wrong because stories
are really not about words or word
choice or anything like that they're
about conveying the power of a character
facing a dilemma that you have no idea
how he or she will will resolve and when
you do that you've got everyone's
attention stories in general are not
plot we think their plot but they're not
their emotions they're their moments
that generate emotion so if you become
more concerned with the things inside
you that feel like they're emotional and
you get those emotions on the page or in
a scene then you can find ways to create
the internal logic of a story to bring
them together so so it's just shifting
from plot into emotion really if you're
a writer I think you have to realize
identification has nothing to do with
who we are
in real life no it only has to do with
emotion it only has to do with empathy
because we are there's nothing in real
life that would make me like Sully or
whatever his name is in Avatar
I'm nothing like Indiana Jones I'm
nothing like the hero of Shrek but that
isn't what that's not why we go to
movies we don't really go to movies to
become characters that are so much like
we are we can see those people like
going home
yeah that's those are the people we want
to get away from what you want to do is
create that empathy using those tools so
we become them on an emotional
psychological level that's the fun of it
so we become a space traveler 200 years
in the future we become a soldier of
fortune we become an ogre
whatever we become a woman on the
Titanic so those two things are really
better thought of as disconnected
completely I think yeah also also along
that line I agree totally with what
Michaels saying but then we can we
connect with characters on an emotional
level and if you take any of the
characters that you've mentioned and
Michael's mentioned and you say okay
that person's life is nothing like mine
I am NOT Shrek I am NOT Indiana Jones
I'm nothing but my life is so much like
him because I suffer and experience all
the emotions that he goes through I have
feelings of abandonment I have feelings
of of pride I have a feelings of
discouragement in other words I can
identify with him emotionally not that I
want to be him or be like him but I like
to know that he is actually not that
different from me in other words there
is a similarity but the similarity is on
the emotional experience all level not
on the action level or the career level
if you take like you mentioned Titanic
there you have the two lovers on Titanic
do we all understand falling in love yes
hopefully we all do do we all understand
being in danger yes do we do do we all
understand fears of death and dying yes
we do dessert have we ever been on the
Titanic no or sinking boat and in other
words we haven't been
but what we can the experience is that
these a good film will allow us to have
with the characters with with this not
identifying with the character except on
the emotional level
and that's where we get hooked and that
that's how we we and but not only
empathize that we project ourselves in
into them and we play them when you read
a script you play all the characters
even when you watch a film you actually
project yourself inside the character to
go on not the adventure of Indiana Jones
but the experience the emotional
experience that right that's the ride
you want to go on and that and that's
what makes us connect potentially with
this film on a very very deep level
makes a viable idea so I came up with
this little acronym of the word problem
because I feel that every story is
really about a problem and it's all
about you know when someone's are
reacting to your script or your pitch or
your logline
what they're mostly thinking consciously
or not is okay what's the problem at the
center of this story does this problem
sound really compelling and entertaining
to watch is an audience gonna care about
this problem that this main character or
these characters are trying to solve
whether it's film television or even
commercial fiction or theatre I think
the same kind of basic premises of you
know how story and ideas for story work
applies to all them which is why the
title mentions stage and fiction they're
looking at what the problem is what's
the nature of the problem or what's the
nature of the goal for the main
character right so I took problem and I
created this acronym from the letters in
the word problem and the book is
basically a presentation of these seven
elements that start with those seven
letters and those are the elements that
I think successful commercially viable
stories that would interest an age and a
manager a producer and editor etc tend
to have you want to hear what they are
so it's just quickly and we can go
deeper if you want the problem at the
center of the story needs to be
punishing relatable original believable
life-altering entertaining and
meaningful so some of those words I
could have used different words but they
wouldn't fit the problem so I kind of
made so they all lined up with those
seven letters
to me that's what the story is what's
the central problem here we could talk
examples if you wanted but pretty much
any genre it's about characters who are
kind of punished usually as they're
trying to resolve some situation and so
it's just becomes second nature to me to
think in terms of what's the problem at
the center of any TV series TV episode
movie story in general and of course
when I look at someone's script or I
just see the log line even I'm like I
said I'm looking at what's the problem
here and sometimes the log line doesn't
even make the problem clear or it
focuses too much on the internal problem
for the characters because sometimes
writers confuse like internal character
arc with external problem and great
stories generally have both but the
external problem is kind of the part
that people really want to know about
when they are assessing your idea it's
like the external problem has to be
really solid the internal arc is a
little more optional but you've got to
have that big external problem typically
in a commercial type project and so
that's what I'm talking about more than
the internal what the character needs to
learn and how they need to grow stuff
which is the arc or the theme or the
flaw you know that kind of stuff
sometimes we writers tend to focus a lot
on that and make that drive all of our
efforts and what I've learned is its it
tends to be better to let that stuff
stay a little flexible until you've
gotten this sort of external problem
worked out and even kind of structured
out a bit because sometimes your sense
of what the theme is or what the
characters growth should be will change
and shift once you've really explored
the external problem the external
challenge that there you know every
scene is typically about them grappling
with and trying to resolve what is the
fear that is crippling in some way the
character at the beginning of the story
and how do they find the courage to
overcome that I talk what I lecture
about the terms I use our identity in
essence because to me this isn't present
in all screenplays you could have a big
action script that doesn't involve a
character arc but for most of the of the
stories that are layered the character
is suffering from some moon something
happened in the past before the movie
began that was so painful that they
believe they've dealt with it but
they've
they sort of suppress it they haven't
blacked it out they know what happened
but they think that doesn't bother me
anymore so in Shrek it was his rejection
or in in Titanic it was rose getting
drummed in by her mother the idea if you
don't have a man to take care of you
you're not going to survive so though
those wounding experiences created this
deep-seated fear and that stuckness that
I talked about at the beginning is just
them living under that fear and it's
preventing them from really doing what
they need to do to be fully to be
fulfilled then as the writer what you
have to do is you have to give that
character a goal you have to dangle a
carrot in front of your hero that is so
enticing either because it's such a big
reward or it's to prevent something
horrible from happening that they are
desperate to go after it so that's the
plot of your story is the journey as
they go after that goal but the inner
journey is about them in pursuing that
goal realizing I'm never gonna get it
unless I can find this courage that I
don't have because I'm too afraid of
this moon from the past of so they start
in this identity this false self and
they have to find a way to get to their
essence in who they truly are as they
gradually find this courage to achieve
the goal and the rule is they can't get
the goal in the end of the movie unless
they found the courage and if they do
find the courage they've got to get
there they've got to win they've got to
get the girl or find the buried treasure
or stop the serial killer or whatever
that goal might be so it's that
intertwining of that outer journey of
the plot and the inner journey that the
hero takes of transformation that really
interests me when I talk about story and
script even in comedy series on
television one thing I often find myself
reminding myself in my own projects and
telling other writers that come to me
and want feedback and stuff is that your
characters should really be in hell and
under siege pretty much all the time
like even if you watch a show like 30
rock means they're slightly dated
references now but like Everybody Loves
Raymond but I could also talk about like
V
or glow or current series if you really
look at what's going on for the
characters that we're following it's
basically their suffering they're under
siege they're in a sort of hell and
they're trying to get out of it pretty
much every episode for us as an audience
it's fun to watch it's fun to watch
their reactions to things and just sort
of how their characters operate and
interact in a comedy in a drama or a
thriller it's fun a different way for
the audience it's fun for us it's never
fun for them you know even in even in
the you know the the save the cat book
the Blake Snider book he talks about the
fun and games section which is the first
half of act 2 in a screenplay in his
world and I think he makes some great
points but the fun and games section
even in that section of the movie which
he calls flooding games I'm often
telling people I don't think your
characters should so much be having fun
or enjoying the situation your
characters are kind of under siege even
in the first half of act 2 they're kind
of struggling suffering being punished
by the situation they're in the
upside-down world they find themselves
in the problem or goal that they're
trying to resolve which they're an
underdog and they're overmatched and the
world is not giving them what they want
that's pretty much every story in my
view in every genre so it's it's it's
interesting how often writers tend to
write scenes of characters kind of
getting along and kind of having
victories and I and I usually say that
you know in a story the victories
generally only come at the very end if
they come anywhere other than the very
end they're usually very short-lived and
often overshadowed by the bigger problem
that still demands resolution because
what keeps the drama or the comedy
moving is that sense of there's a
problem I'm trying to solve this problem
there's this goal I'm trying to reach
this goal problem and goal are kind of
two sides of the same thing some stories
the goal is just to solve the problem in
other stories the goal is its own
positive thing and the problem is I
haven't reached the goal so it's kind of
like problem slash goal I think of it as
like the same thing but that being
difficult and unresolved and also
changing and evolving and usually
getting worse and more
over the course of the story or the TV
episode or the TV series is kind of this
key thing that I'm always looking at
medic audiences and certainly industry
professionals are looking at and
evaluating consciously or not do I feel
the problem is compelling and big is it
getting worse you know are the
characters struggling is it changing and
evolving but generally in a direction of
worse and more difficult until the kind
of final battle at the end where the
resolution finally happens so that's why
problem is that word that I think I'm
always referring to when I'm talking
about a story
right up front is what is the story what
is the movie story or what is the TV
story that's where the logline comes in
that everybody is so happy to talk about
but it really is a one sentence
expression of your intention if you
can't get that down you might want to go
back in and and really re-examine you
know is there something to right here so
first of all ask yourself what is that
one sentence expression once you have
that then you want to ask yourself you
know well what turns you on about that
idea okay based on what excites you
about that idea now ask well what are
the scenes that express that excitement
you know that really really show those
beats that are that you have to show on
screen you know and then keep working
backwards from there okay who are the
people that populate that scene what do
they say so if you start big picture and
then you keep sort of breaking it down
to the things that excite you the people
in it what they say I think I think
those are the questions to ask you as
you're writing what's the genre as it's
studio or independent who's your
protagonist what's their goal with their
flaw who's the main relationship with
what's driving this story who's your
audience who's the antagonist what's
their goal in their flaw you know what's
the narrative question driving the film
so like every story you should be able
to sum it up in one main question like
so like dial if I was diehard would be
like you know will you know New York cop
trapped you know will this New York cop
free his wife and hostages from some
European terrorists you have them
trapped in skyscrapers like it's like
one question right like so what's your
narrative question driving this story
and what's your theme and what's your
theme attic question like what's why are
you telling us that the ematic question
is like the question you pose to the
audience it could be a moral question it
could be or something else but some
question you want them to think about
like it is family really just people
you're related to or is it something
more you know it could be a fee Matic
question it's it's not overtly stated in
the story but it's kind of like in the
film subconscious it's like what you
know
the film is really kind of about and
then your theme is how you answer that
question by the end that's your theme
your your story so like what are those
things and I might even be missing a
couple ayat but off the top of my head
those are like a lot of and if you can't
answer those questions or if those
questions don't make sense together a
lot of times there's the problems with
the story so for example if you say your
protagonist goal is my private
protagonist goal is to grab the banana
and what's your antagonist goal to grab
the orange well they're in two different
movies they're never going to intersect
there's no conflict great your
protagonist grabs the banana and your
antagonist grabs the orange movies over
and that's a very simplistic example but
those are the kind of things but on a
deeper level we look at my goal wall
here there's a few things that aren't
making sense you say your main
relationship is character and character
BB or antagonist character C then I even
I mean your main relationship that's
moving the story forward so why are they
your why are they your antagonist the 12
questions is a great sort of reset okay
let me square away I mean you know even
if I've done this a hundred times every
story is different in a lot of times you
miss those those important details and
once I think that twelve questions are
are making sense now and things are
tying together like oh now see how the
protagonist goal ties into your theme
okay now that being starts puzzle pieces
start making sense then I say okay now
now let's work out a synopsis three or
four paragraphs you know first X 2nd
half 3rd ad or whatever just so we can
say ok now let's make sure from just a
broad story standpoint that all those
questions are being addressed and then
from there you can expand it to a full
treatment scene outline and it's then
you start writing your script cuz like I
explained to them a lot easier to
develop the story in a synopsis form or
a treatment form than it is to keep
rewriting the script when there's
fundamental problems in it you don't
start building the building it's slanted
I will start taking out some bricks and
try to get sure you work all of that out
on the design phase and the blueprint
phase and so that's what I try to get
them to do that and the 12 questions is
to me is like okay that's that beginning
that organic seed that we need to plant
to make a healthy tree grow the best
questions a screenwriter can ask
themselves to make the story better one
thing is is how is this my story how is
whatever this story is how does it
relate to me so that I can use my
emotions to go through to tell this
story better because what
the weirdest part about being a
screenwriter is that we sit in a room
alone we are isolated from society we
basically are cut off from emotional
situations we hate conflict we hate all
of these things that then we're going to
use those are the elements we need to
use to make our story passionate and and
emotional and all of those things so all
the things that we sort of fear to deal
with we now have to deal with and so
basically look at the story one of the
things with assignments that I have to
find a doorway into an assignment so if
I am offered a deal I'm offered some
thing that I read a book whatever some
assignment where they're gonna hire you
to write the script I have to look at
that and go how is this story my story
so I can tell it honestly because if it
has nothing to do with me then I'm just
taking money and typing and the bad part
about that is the script will not work
the worst part about it is then you may
have to do it a couple of rewrites after
that on a script that becomes torture
it's like I'm just typing this I'm just
writing it I have no connection to the
story so then it becomes work and you
know if any of us you know wanted to be
wanted to do work we wouldn't be writers
powerful stories ask questions so they
they work in such a way that the
audience is constantly wondering why did
that happen or where is this taking us
and and as soon as you and you have tit
you can't ask the question and then I
answer it at the end you have to ask a
little question you have to answer it in
the next scene or the next chapter or
whatever it is but then you have to pose
another question and so really a
powerful story is one that continues to
ask questions and deliver meaningful
answers and and satisfactory answers I
don't remember who said that but it's
something that I've definitely followed
in my work and it's a way that I a tool
that I use to keep the audience engaged
and I was with two other groups and they
were asking questions that you could
have found through research through
reading a book
for reading the Tom Clancy book I was
asking questions about if you're on a
submarine for four months what's it like
what is your life like how these
relationships between crew members go
you HOT bunk on a submarine so you don't
even have personal space your bed is
your bed for 12 hours then it's another
guy's bed for 12 hours and so you don't
even have your own bed and so I was
asking questions like what if the guy
that you're sharing the bed with stinks
and you know the answer was dude we all
stink after a while you know and it's
like you just have to get over it and if
they talked about I asked about the
smells on the submarine because imagine
living in a porta potty for four months
and that's kind of one of the elements
of living on a submarine so I got all of
the personal stuff that was how their
how their lives are affected by their
job because the technical stuff I could
read but that stuff you can only get
from people so that's you know when
you're doing research you've got to talk
to the people you know do the police
ride-alongs you got a you know and when
you're on the police ride-along ask
questions that are weird because you're
gonna lot you're liable to get a good
answer if you ask normal questions you
get the what they're going to tell you
you know they sort of have the the
generic answers ready but if you ask the
strange questions then you get the this
stuff I think who my audience is you
know it's the story interesting enough
usually for my horror stuff it's like is
there enough is there enough stuff in
here to care about the characters but am
I also coming up enough scare so we
haven't seen before those are the kind
of things I ask myself like it's
interesting cuz I love doing it and I've
done it for so long that it's it's
definitely it's not easy work at all
like people because people don't
understand like again they especially
when you're threading a script together
and you know dissecting and making sure
that everything kind of lines up in
pieces together you want to put your
best foot forward but you also realize
that a lot of times that once you sell
the script and it's out of your hands a
lot of that stuff just goes out the
window so that's why I'm not as harsh
when I see a movie I like that I reserve
judgment on the writer until I see read
the actual screenplay because you just
never know what changes from page to
screen but for me it's usually
especially with
it's always horror films it's like you
know do I think this is also do I think
this is going to strike a chord to
people like you know final destination
dealt with death which is kind of a
universal fear so I try to think of
concepts that will tap into something
that's will reach a wide audience you
know I'm not gonna lie about that like I
do try to you know you you want to hit
as many people as you can I think with
your concept but that's what I love
about horror the horror genre I think
themes are you know the fears that we
have most people are universal fears
that aren't you know regulated to like
one region or one part of the world or
or any you know I think we all kind of
have the same fears deep down so that's
one thing I think I love about horror is
you can kind of tackle a whole bunch of
different kind of stories and still have
it play well it around the world members
have to figure out how to get out there
in the world how to get out of there for
many reasons they have to figure out how
to get out of their home and out of
their comfort zone because one of the
things that happens is as we shrink our
world we shrink what we can write about
and we end up writing stories you know
as my two years in my in my apartment
after selling the script were just like
smaller and smaller and smaller stories
because I was not getting out in the
world and being part of the world and
it's one of those things where you you
know life experience is the is the raw
material for your scripts and the more
life experience you have whatever that
is you know broken hearts you know all
that stuff is all part of what makes you
who you are so you write the script but
also if you don't see the world out
there people often online now people
will ask questions of research questions
and they go well how do I know about
this and my answer to that is you find
the person that does that for a living
and you ask them you don't ask me I'm a
writer what the hell do I know but if
you want to know about stuff you go out
and ask those people because part of
that is you get out of your comfort zone
and into the world but you also get the
real answers and so I did a script
called recall that was about the auto
industry and I went to when it existed
the van nuys GM plant and across the
street was a bar and I went into that
bar and I bought pitchers of beer and I
asked guys that worked on the
just to tell me about their lives and I
got all kinds of just stuff that I could
never get from Google never get from you
know going to the library it was all
stuff that was their real life and one
of the things that made it into my
script was this guy that talked about
how his hands were so calloused that he
was afraid to touch his wife and I was a
real heartbreaking story that's like one
of those things that you don't think
about anything about guys work in an
assembly line you don't think that
there's going to be this thing that's
going to affect their their romantic
emotional life and those were the
stories the great story
day one you would start with obviously
the idea what's your concept so I think
concept is important once you know your
concept and there's ways to make that
concept appealing the class I'm teaching
tomorrow morning will be on concept how
to make sure your concept is high I mean
by high concept I don't you know there's
a there's a term for I concept in
Hollywood but for me it means that there
is high appeal meaning that as soon as
you had the idea you go oh there's
something about it that just like hooks
you and you go wow I want to find out
what it's about or how it's resolved so
that's what you should at first the next
thing that you should think about for me
and I know there's controversy about
that whether you do that first or later
for me I need to know what it's about
you know is what I mean this whole story
will be a reflection of what you're
trying to say like what's your theme
what's the meaning of your story and if
you don't know what it is well you could
try developing a story and write many
drafts and then and then you figure out
what it is you go ok that's possible a
lot of writers do that and that's okay
but I always use paddy Chayefsky x'
quote which says lucky is the writer who
knows his theme from the beginning
because once you know that you you've
got I always suggest you write it in big
letters and put it in front of your
computer so you see it at all times
because most of your characters most so
you've seen your whole story will be a
reflection of what you're trying to sell
your theme and so it's better to know it
right away it'll save you a lot of time
from trying to write many drafts and
then come back to it and cut what
doesn't work and create you know new
things but if you know themes so so for
me it's concept then theme and then once
you know your theme then you can create
your characters because your character
will be a reflection especially if your
character has an arc will be a
reflection of that theme and so you know
where your character is going to start
and now you know where character is
going to end and then you can figure out
your scenes and your story in terms of
all the stuff I'm talking about
character connection and motivational
and stuff those are details that you can
add later but what I'm talking about is
what the foundation of stories which is
what is your story about and how does
your character transform to reflect that
theme that you're trying to convey
and yeah that's the foundation when I
sit down to write something usually I
start with a concept
I'm very concept driven just because I
think that's working at a studio for so
long I know that the concept is what's
going to get people's attention or not
get it so I start with using a concept
and then I think of some scares as well
and then start you know with building a
story around the concept is how I
approach but I know a lot of people
start from like characters and some
people start from a story so it's
everybody's got their own personal kind
of creative style and how they on how
they work but for me I always I always
start with the concept of the story and
I try to think at least some concept
that's kind of high concept that you can
kind of if you tell somebody in a minute
and they're like oh that sounds cool you
know so that's that's kind of where I
start off when I'm writing so I tried to
think a lot about whose story it is and
I'm fine if it's not just one person's
story you know like I think I tried to
think about the point of view and
because these leads me to think about
the emotions you know so I questioned
myself a lot how they feel you know and
then I usually try to find like a time
frame that's something very important
like in this beginners course it was
three days in now like with the they
were film it was three months summer you
know so for me it's important to kind of
find yeah it's a this timeframe you know
and then I think a lot about also about
the backstory of the characters because
there is something that I I love to
portray a specific moment of the lives
of these characters I like when you feel
that they have a lot of things that
happen between them before you know so
so it's like basically we as a human
beings are who we are because of all of
our backstory you know so I love
observing people like in real life and
see how their relationships work you
know and and I always wonder why you
know so I try to kind of imagine their
backstory so that's that's like my
little game with the people I mean you
know also so that's something that I
really liked
as well when I started writing and thing
okay so the audience is gonna see this
moment by what's behind that like what's
before all that you know I have inside
out writing and outside in writing and
the outside in will tend to be something
where there's kind of an external story
and then so you're kind of you've got
the container a little bit and then
you're figuring out all of the ways that
you're furnishing and arranging what's
in that container and generating some
new stuff but and then when occasionally
I I have the luxury of doing kind of
what I call the inside-out where you
just you have almost nothing you have
like you woke up in the middle of the
night with like an image in your head or
you know you're just kind of this very
fragmentary thing like a grain of sand
and and then it's like you're making
stone narrative stone soup you're like
here's the pebble and then you know do
you know the story of Stone Soup you
know they go around they get the meat
and the carrots and and everything and
then it's more like it's like found art
like just pulling all of the the things
from your life your memories and what's
going on and and you're kind of building
it out from from this little thing and
it becomes something where you really
didn't have much of an idea what it was
gonna be at all and so that's that's
pretty fun I like to sit and think about
the idea and then I like to think about
the character who that woman or man is
and what they're like
and what their world looks like and then
I just start to think about what the
movie might look like in my head and
once I sort of start seeing the movie
itself in my head then I start writing
it I don't know how it's gonna end
necessarily unless it's a thriller if
it's a thriller I need to know how it's
gonna end so I can know where I gotta go
if that makes sense you know because you
always want to have that ending that
people go call so you think of the
ending first
what would be a cool hall and then okay
now how do I get there
so I go backward if it's a thrower if
it's not a thrower if it's just a story
about people and life and love or
whatever it is then I don't really think
that much about what's gonna happen I
just sort of think about the people and
where they are and where I want them to
be what the world's like what they enjoy
there's usually a lot of wine involved
because I enjoy some wine
I think the first steps when I when I
begin to write is a lot of thinking
about thinking about it like I don't I'm
not really good at just sitting down and
starting to bang it out and I don't
really
oftentimes I don't write an outline it's
not like I have to make an outline first
and then write the script so for me
usually it's a couple of ideas that just
won't go away and so if those ideas
won't go away then that means that
there's something hopefully there's
something there and I just let it
percolate and it has a sort of magnetic
if it's a good idea and these are rare
cuz it's not like I have like never been
one of those guys that just like you
know I was able to spin a good yarn and
have a million stories I want to tell
but in the case of search and rescue it
was just a couple of ideas started to
sort of bind together and I think some
of them were ideas that I had for other
movies that didn't go anywhere like in
other words they were that's and it's
now that I think about it they were
there were several different ideas and
characters that had been I had been
developing for other movies that didn't
sustain themselves they were good but
they didn't for some reason they didn't
belong and whatever movie I was think I
was trying to make and so it all started
to kind of combine into this one film
but you know what I you know that's
specific to this particular movie and
every writing every writing process is
different you know if somebody comes to
me and says I need you to write
megashark versus giant octopus in two
weeks that's a different that's a
different process that's when you sit
down and you know figure out you know
okay act one this that should happen
then this should you know that's when I
do that so so you know work-for-hire
that has to be of a you know I think
that's easier as a simpler genre is
easier to do than this but I really did
have to think about it and I really did
have to draw from a lot of things that
had been dormant ideas that had been
dormant that sort of all sort of
coalesced to form this thing that's how
it started then I did then of course I
had to sit down and write everyday like
everybody else you have to write it you
know you can think about it all day
woman but you have to write it for me I
let it sit for a while you know I let it
sit for a while and I I tend to what
I've learned for me over the years from
my own personal kind of instrument is
that when I first started I would get
excited about an idea and I would tell
everyone about it I would call my my
brother I would tell my friend I would
tell I would call you and tell you I
would call him and tell you know and
then because because you're excited
about it and I think that's a good
energy to have when you have a story to
tell but what I do now is that I don't
tell anyone about it and I think that's
important for me because I think you
wanna it's almost like a boxer you want
to get into the ring with as much energy
as possible so that when the bell rings
you're coming out you know swinging and
and what I discovered over the years is
that when you spend all your energy
telling people about it and then you get
in front of the computer you have no
energy you're done telling people about
it right so for me I keep it all bagged
up I get excited about it and I talk to
myself about it and I think about it a
whole lot and I get it to the point
where it's about for me it's about
seventy percent done I never want to get
to the point where it's hundred percent
done because you want to allow for some
room for inspiration and changes so I
give it to it for me I get it to the
point where it's about 70 percent
figured out and then there's all this
kind of energy kind of boiling and then
I wake up really early in the morning
have my coffee and I just sort of like
spend all that energy getting it out
onto the page and then it's on the page
and then you have a little bit of
you know kind of security and then you
can maybe tell people about one scene or
whatever but you know III think it's
good to keep the energy wrapped up well
it depends on which script depends on
the story the story is coming from
generally speaking I don't have a
backstory beyond a sentence or two okay
you know I don't know what they you know
what they were like in sixth grade or
anything like that I just kind of take
from people in real life or combine
people in real life or think of people I
know when I again I just bounced these
characters off each other knowing that
this one is you know sort of feisty and
this one is sort of mellow and this one
is sort of this and then you can add on
the second and the third adjectives sort
of as you as you go but I think in the
beginning if I'm gonna introduce a
character that I've never in my life you
know I say you know Joe 25 persistent
you know I don't know I'll say two
adjectives and then I'll just move
forward that's it it's real real quick
and then I don't necessarily have to
deliver on those adjectives if I feel
like it's going in another direction
maybe he's not persistent maybe he's
maybe he's lackluster maybe he's lazy I
don't know I have to like write him out
a little bit I have to let him talk in
order to know but the dynamic between
characters is important in the chemistry
so I always start there that's where I
start and the story and the concept I
have as like you know a sentence it's
just well it's not an outline it's not
an it that's not detailed or in depth
the first draft will be detailed to the
absolute to the extent it needs to be in
order to be concise to the point and not
dragging anywhere where we don't need to
be in in particularly in the action
so we enter this room am I gonna tell
you that it's got blue walls and a couch
no because the characters are what are
important and the room is for the
director that's not my job on the
screenwriter the room is for the
director to decide and if you're the
director and the screenwriter a great or
whatever but you know people respond to
characters first and foremost and so
that's just really the most detailed
part of my screenplays the action I
would say is the briefest part of my
scripts I will spend quite a bit of time
outlining before I even write the fold
like I usually have a complete full
outline and then jump into the story so
I'll have a really specific idea of the
objective of every single scene and
ultimately it saves me time when I first
started writing I was anti outline I
kind of had the attitude you know it's
the young attitude of just like you know
I'm just gonna write and my my guts
gonna tell me what's right and what it's
meaningful and stuff like that and that
works for a lot of writers but I noticed
that I would hit a lot of dead ends
and I became emotionally attached to
those dead ends and then it became
really hard to rewrite until I just
drove my stories off the cliff and so
little by little the more I you know
honestly that Ron Media 24-point thing
was huge because it was so simple you
could literally sit there I just plot
out a story in an hour and you'd have a
really good idea of where I was going
and then from there you're you know
that's to me that's when you go from
like you know discovering your story to
actually becoming craftsman or a crass
person where you're working on the story
and taking control of it and then you
start to take a step back and then you
know it's almost like a render machine
you're rendering your story before you
ever sit down and write it so then the
script really just becomes kind of a
secondary artifact of all the work that
you've put into it so yeah I spend a lot
of time outlining it it's and it's you
know a lot of people feel like it takes
away from the creative process usually
that's kind of the writer saying well I
want to be in the audience too
and I want to experience and be
surprised by it but outlining doesn't
take away from that because what happens
when you sit down like you've outlined
you've got your outline right here and
then when you're writing you put
yourself in the moment you're you're in
the skin of the writer or the character
and you you're experiencing it and then
if your gut tells you to try something
different try something different see
where it goes
so you're still you know the whole
Gardner versus architect the pan servers
a plot or kind of thing I call it what
is it the the assassin versus the
Berserker basically the idea that like
the the planner versus the person that
just sees what happens next and I think
it's important to to understand the
consequences of the choices you're
making but the whole process of writing
is an experiment art is an experiment
and the out the only thing that rules it
is do we make it emotionally resonant
for somebody else and as artists we get
to decide how much that is like how we
build that relationship so for me it
feels like it's like like a map you're
zooming in and you know you can do the
the street view where you're in the
character and you're just driving along
and you're like yeah I feel this I'm
going through this Street and that's
when you're writing but then you pull
back you zoom out and you see the
overview of where you're going and
that's the outline but generally
speaking the average person would
benefit from taking the time to plan out
where their story's going to go have a
good idea of how it's going to end and
then you know work toward that well I'll
come up with an idea right or I'll come
up with a character or come up with a
theory and most of the time for me it's
like it it's a thesis it's something and
I think that might be because I I read I
love to read so much literature and I'm
gonna kind of come from philosophy that
I develop a thesis or something that I
want to say and then I find characters
that I think I can embody that purpose
and that that can function in a story
kind of
carries this idea throughout it so I can
communicate what I want to say in a
story and through characters so always
come starts with an idea or a thesis or
a theory that I want to talk about and
the characters in the story kind of all
fall in line from there then I'll just
you know kind of binge watch a bunch of
movies that apply and I'll just write
you know I carry a little notebook
around me everywhere I go so cuz I don't
really type that much I mean I type but
I I don't really write my script until
I've written it handwritten in a bunch
of times and it's a bunch of different
ways and I've kind of flushed out my
characters and that only then do I write
the plot because I think that Lisa right
now and the stories that I'm trying to
tell it's the characters motivate the
plot rather than the plot motivating the
character so I want to really know my
characters like they're friends of mine
like they're my best friends my
childhood friends and so once I know
them I kind of know the world once I
know the world I know the story I think
everyone is different sometimes you'll
get just a logline sometimes you'll see
an image sometimes you'll get the name
of it but not know specifically what the
story is yet usually what I try to do is
like as I strike I have like this what
is it called speech notes I think it is
there's a app called speech notes and so
I'll start to get information little
bits and pieces about a story
I'll start jotting them down in my phone
and usually once I kind of have a good
idea of what that story is I always
start with the outline like I anytime
before I write a script I always outline
the entire script scene one scene to
scene three and then I'll have like a
couple of a couple of
lines of information to describe the dis
de'cine so this is how I like avoid
writer's block like I always outline the
entire script from front to back so when
I start writing I just write from from
from that those script notes but yeah I
usually start there I start with just a
an idea outline it I always decide early
on what the lighting is gonna be how the
camera is gonna move the color
everything like before I even go into
pre-production like I I am I have a full
idea of the style the look of it the
pacing of it the tone of it and yeah
once I do that I start writing the
script I have a team that I work with
and I usually tell them pretty pretty
early on like what the what the concept
is and how I want to approach it and
yeah I sort of go from that I will say
one thing that I think could be very
interesting to people that are writers
is is what I do is I outline a script
very meticulously and my outlines are
about 25 pages to 30 pages long and then
when I go to write the actual first
draft I will not read one word of what
I've written until I've written the
whole script so for my first pass on a
screenplay I start from the beginning
and then I just go and I go all the way
through until I'm done without having
read one word of it and it takes about
three weeks so in three weeks I've
written a whole draft and it's a lot of
fun because there is no judgment
whatsoever I'm just writing straight
through and then I go through and very
meticulously work through the scenes and
that takes two to three weeks and then
in six weeks I have a draft but it's
really two drafts because I've done one
straight through and then one this sort
of meticulous work through and I
we'll say that the second phase of it
the meticulous works roof phase is the
least enjoyable part of the whole
process because it's the most critical
we're at just for a couple weeks it's
just I have to work through these scenes
and and and then but I just do it and
then after that I have a draft to work
off of and then there's many drafts
after that but it's it's I have this
nice foundation
staring at the blank page because by the
time I'm ready to write a scene
I've already had like pages of writing I
can't it's like the slingshot you're
just like slowly like preparing like
getting all the scenes getting the
character getting the plot the conflict
you know what every character wants so
when you sit down you're ready to write
you let go and you're just flying you
know but it's but it really comes down
to everybody discovering their own
process you know and I'm not a purist
like lots of people don't outline and
they're very good writers are very
successful and a lot of that's the
tuition or their experience that informs
it I don't have writer's block I don't
it's not a very dramatic thing there's
no inspiration I don't wait for
inspiration I say inspiration is for
amateurs amateurs get inspired
professionals just go do it and and it's
not even very dramatic anymore I mean I
just go and I know I'm gonna do it I
mean I know I'm gonna get stuff done and
it's very productive to be honest with
you I find that that I get a lot of
writing done because I don't make a big
deal about it I don't it's not this big
dramatic thing for me I just show up and
then I just get going and like I said it
takes sometimes an hour an hour and a
half to actually get started
occasionally two hours and then we and
then I just start going and I try to be
non-judgmental of it and I don't sit
there and question it or think that I'm
not talented or I just try and do it and
then and then there's a phase when you
have to edit it and go through it and
that can be more you know that's a more
critical part of your brain but I do my
best to not beat myself up about it and
if I don't like something I just change
it I just keep working on it and working
on it and not turn it into some big
melodramatic artists struggle I don't I
don't view it that way at all I don't
necessarily have like a list of
screenplays like read these screenplays
and then you're gonna be an awesome
screenwriter it's more give yourself
exposure to a lot of different styles of
writing a lot of different genres
I love Aaron Sorkin obviously right so
the social network that's one that's a
screenplay that I've read over and over
again I really love Alex Garland's ex
machina
that's one of my favorite films it's a
really well-done screenplay again
it's you know a theme and a genre that
I'm interested in
lately I have actually I've been
revisiting the truman show that that
screenplay because when when that came
out it was it was very you know novel it
was a very interesting idea and it
actually shaped me in a lot of ways
because either you have those moments
where you're like at my on The Truman
Show like how powerful of a screenplay
to be able to do that and to create like
a psychosis everybody says you have to
write and read every day because it's
true if you're if you're writing every
day you know the next day you're gonna
you're gonna write a little better than
you did the day before and in four years
you're gonna be a much better writer
than you were four years ago
and I think a lot of writers you're
waiting to for the world to give you
permission to pursue your craft and you
just need to you need to give yourself
that permission you need to show up and
say okay I'm gonna do this and I might
not be very good right now or you know
maybe I am great and I don't know it yet
you won't know either way unless you put
yourself out there and sitting down
every day whether that's you know for an
hour in the morning an hour in the
evening somewhere in between the timing
doesn't matter and it really doesn't
even matter you know if you're writing a
thousand words or if you're writing
fifty the important thing is that you're
writing so when I wrote my first
screenplay
I didn't know this is the difference
between writing a screenplay and when I
was directing before work my first
screenplay of course see if is is like
you know you I don't think as a
screenwriter I don't think that you can
really be assigned a screenwriter if you
have a study state feels you know in
vibrate a lot of screenplays a tons of
screen planes before I even started
writing screenplays I read see if is
booking I've continued to read his books
you know but tons of screenplays
so when I first bought my first
screenplay you know and that's not that
you know it never got produced of course
and I took it out people Randy he's like
that's pretty decent but it wasn't good
it wasn't good so
only I were it was only after after
writing at least 10 screenplays before I
actually decided you know if I actually
produce more stuff they should have
beside them a list of the 100 most
recent screenplays that they have read
the published ones the successful ones
ok I'll give you a break make it 50 you
are not ready to write until you are
very well-read and well-versed in the
literature you are proposing to create
and in this in this place it's
screenwriting I would say systematize
your organization the first thing you
have to do see a really bad habit that
most screenwriters have is they've got a
great idea and they're cooking and they
just start writing screenplay I'm
writing screenplay pages oh boy and it's
fun but it's going nowhere ultimately
without a plan and a very well thought
out the hard work is in the outline and
it has to be a very complete outline and
you have to have confidence that all
story problems have been addressed so
the first thing you have to do is the
dirty work the outline write yourself I
would say here real goal sequences
because I happen to think it and I
happen to know that it works but however
you know beat sheet however they do it
have a very complete outline and then
good bloody luck it's it's it's a lot of
work and then I would also say yeah you
write it on a little piece of paper and
tape it above your desk write badly with
pride know
no writer's block none just write badly
with pride write a piece of piece of
junk
you know if you haven't if you just
sitting there staring at the wall for an
hour okay
what would you write if you were just
really writing trash really writing
garbage go for because you never know
yeah when the real idea is the depth of
what you are doing will be sparked you
just don't know you don't know what that
story is and and you know it's not that
cliche write what you know
because I've never written what I quote
unquote know I I write fantastical
worlds and and and and and supernatural
stories and all of that but write what
you feel and write what's in your heart
and write something that means something
to you and you know I I was a script
reader for God probably a decade and I
and the and and I was reading seven
eight scripts a week and the rare one
was the great script and when you found
that that was a very exciting day at the
office
and sometimes the really terrible
scripts were kind of they were fun
because they were so god-awful but the
ones that got really exhausting and
really enervating is a script reader
who's sitting there and has to read a
script synopsize that write a comment
about it then pick up another one and
read it and so were the ones that you
could tell were written by people who
were looking at what last year's hit was
and trying to imitate it and those were
deadly and they were they weren't good
they weren't bad they were safe and
mediocre and any writer any young writer
any old writer anyone who's just
starting to write anything write
something that you feel write write
write write something that comes from
the heart and and and people may not
think that Betelgeuse is a personal
movie
it's an intensely personal movie it was
intensely personal for Michael and me
and and you know I I didn't know I had a
theme until I had enough work to realize
I had a theme and almost everything I've
written are about broken families who
are put back together in some bizarre
way but there but but because I came
from a broken family and and what and
and and so so the there's a I like to
think that my work has a sense of heart
and a sense of compassion and a sense of
humanity in it no matter how bizarre it
is no matter how weird the worlds get
and and you you got you got to write
something that you feel on something
that you have some passion for or just
why do it it's too hard it's just it's
it's not an easy job and and I
personally can't imagine saying well
this was a hit now so I'm gonna I'm
gonna write my version of that I don't
really it's not really what I care about
what I feel but I can imitate it well
enough I can't imagine spending a year
of your life doing that but people do it
all the time and they usually write
mediocre scrubs the beating yourself up
and I have no talent or this is terrible
or I'll work with a writer and they'll
say oh that was and I said don't
don't worry about it don't worry about
if it's good or bad just let's just take
a look at it and see what what could be
improved there's no reason to be so
caustic and hostile about the material
it's just words on its screen you can
change them it's just changing so that's
very much something that guides me and
in my work it is tough I think to be
really original and you know it goes
back to your question about writing
things that are really personal to you
you know sometimes the most original
things do come from taking your real
life or taking something you wit
or experienced and using that as fodder
for materials so there there is there
can be a value for that if you can also
do what I talked about which is find a
way to have perspective on it so you can
make it viable entertaining compelling
to you know millions of people that
don't know you it's not an easy thing to
do but you know originality is it's a
tricky one because you can only be so
original because if so many things have
already been done right so many types of
stories and genres and types of story
situations I mean I just saw eighth
grade last night yeah which you know it
was a very original voice but it's about
something that we've seen four million
examples of which is a kind of misfit
teen who the popular people are mean to
trying to find their way in the social
universe of school like is there
anything that's been done more often
than that but yet you watch the movie
and because it felt authentic and real
and specific and vivid and done not in
exactly the way we've seen it before and
it had some currency because there was a
whole social media aspect to it where
she has like a vlog and she's on
Instagram all the time you know it feels
like it's very much about that problem
for today's 8th graders in a certain
setting so you update it you make a
current you make it specific I think
that's the thing it's not that it has to
be an idea that is so out there and
different and special because sometimes
that can be a trap if you try to be too
original sometimes you end up writing
things that are contrived or hard to
believe or hard to understand because
your focus is on it has to be different
from everything else when a writer focus
too much on originality I wrote in this
book
sometimes they're doing at the expense
of these other important elements of
what makes a viable story idea like it
may not be as compelling or as
entertaining or as relatable or these
other things because they're mainly
focused on yeah but no one's ever seen
it before
doesn't matter though if no one's ever
seen it before if it doesn't grab the
audience or the reader and the ways that
great stories always have so you always
have to balance the need for originality
with those other elements that being
said you're right that an original voice
is highly valued in a new writer but
it's like finding a way to have that
original I think authentic
that authenticity where things feel so
real so believable but so like well
observed and unique and we haven't seen
it quite this way before because
something in this writers way of seeing
the world and people came up with this
version of it that is very memorable
even if it's within the context of
something that is somewhat familiar you
know like a like you people get Napoleon
Dynamite in its day kind of the same
thing
very original voice but it's about an
awkward teen who doesn't fit in and
people you know push him into lockers
you know kind of thing but when you
watch it you're mainly focused on the
authenticity the originality of it not
noticing that this is a story form or a
genre or a type of story problem that
we've seen endless variations on before
us it's kind of like you're taking
something that's been done in terms of a
genre usually but you're putting a very
fresh unique current specific spin on it
I'd ask them if they had an idea and
then I would just say pull out your
laptop or your notebook with your pen
and start writing it I wouldn't I
wouldn't even tell them about format I
would just be like described a movie
everybody knows what a movie is
everybody knows everybody's seen it
they're like our visual vocabulary is so
high especially now 2018-2019 I mean you
know anybody can describe it that the
problem is we still when we start
educating people we're like read six
books six books take this course do this
stuff watch this video you know like
it's like but not this video yeah yeah
no I need you to watch this video but
that's what I would do if somebody was
like I want to write a movie and I don't
know anything about it I'd be like what
do you want to write about like what's
your idea and they'd probably have the
idea they're not like well I don't know
what the idea is though they're gonna be
like well actually I want to write off
this guy who wants to do this thing and
I'd be like okay start describing it
just describe it and then I might say
something like Trudeau don't talk up
don't describe their thoughts and don't
describe their feeling
any character don't describe the insides
just describe what you would see on them
on a movie screen you know just like and
you know exterior house day man walks
across and gets in the car drives away
you know do not care about doing
anything wrong
just spill your guts just tell us the
movie write down the whole movie we'll
figure all that other stuff later you
can figure out where things are supposed
to be later you can figure out
everything I mean you know there's so
many stories about that where they
didn't know what they were doing you
know they wrote bridesmaids that way
they didn't know like they brought they
bought screenwriting for dummies or
something like that right so it's like
that fresh voice it's like ah it breaks
my heart thinking about all the people
that have that think they have because
we've created this industry where it's
all coded and they got to go take oh you
got to learn you have to learn structure
you have to learn this you've got to
learn all these things you don't know
what a screenplay is man you got to know
what the rules are before you break them
that's all crap to sell books and all
sorts of stuff it doesn't it's if we god
please bring them in that don't know
anything about movies and maybe we'll
have better movies I mean that's the
problem it's like it's like all this
other stuff it's like bringing that
person it's just like I have as a
teacher I have had people come in with
formatting that's just like doesn't ah
they don't know what they don't have
access to final trap I don't know what
they're writing and it's the most
authentic slice of life funny succinct
observational genius stuff and they
don't know and if the reason why it
exists is because they haven't learned
anything about screenwriting yet and
then once you start teaching them then
all of a sudden they they don't know
what they're doing then they don't then
they lose their emotional connection
they lose that story four-year-olds know
how to tell a story they know how to
tell a story ask a five-year-old what
happened today at school well we went in
beginning middle and end the inciting
incident you can tape it you can go
citing it sit so you guys should film
car
interview a friggin ten-year-old and
then put the little flags in and be like
wow they know all the structure already
so I don't have to go to so-and-so
person's course or I don't have to take
Gordy's class or anything you know you
don't have to spend any money and keep
your voice that's the most important
thing I was at it's like don't lose your
voice
don't lose your instincts your childlike
instincts for telling stories it's like
that's what guides us and I always go
back to that I'm like I don't care the
thing I just wrote for somebody that in
all likelihood people who are watching
this video will see I don't know what
the structure is I don't know where the
act breaks are at it and it's over a
hundred and fifty pages okay it was a
writer I mean and it's probably gonna be
seen by people watching this video
directed by a very very good top
director this is going to happen and I
have no idea what the structure of that
is I literally just took my ideas
plotted out the thing now am i following
the rules of character and emotional
engagement to like develop and
everything things you can reflect back
on it be like how do I make this better
but when you're telling me when
somebody's like what's the five-minute
version of like somebody wants to write
a movie that's they watch this video
what I just said
you